-Last time you were here you had
just come back from Asia.
You'd been doing touring there,
and now this time you're just
back from Europe.
How was your Europe travels?
-You know, I got back on Sunday.
So I'm still
a little bit delirious.
-Mm-hmm.
-I mean, the transatlantic
flight, that is no joke, right?
I mean, I guess
that's the only option, right,
to get across the Atlantic.
[ Laughter ]
-Is a flight.
-Trans is the only way.
-Right?
You never really --
there's no people like,
"You know what? I jet-skied."
You know?
[ Laughter ]
But it's an insane flight.
People are messed up
after that flight, for days.
They're like, "I need a day.
I need a day."
But it doesn't seem that hard.
You're like, "It was hard."
I had to sit in a comfortable
chair for six hours.
[ Laughter ]
And watch movies.
I felt like
I was being waterboarded.
[ Laughter ]
People complain.
It used to take six weeks.
-Yeah.
-It used to take six weeks
to get from Europe
to the Western Hemisphere,
and even back then people were
like, "That's great." You know?
[ Laughter ]
"That's good.
Like how long did it take?"
"Six weeks."
"Oh, that's good."
"Yeah, I was productive.
I read every book that's ever
been printed."
[ Laughter ]
You know?
But that's how Columbus --
he, you know, got from Spain to
the Western Hemisphere,
six weeks.
And you know, he got here and he
was like, "I need a day."
[ Laughter ]
You know?
"I am so boatlagged."
[ Laughter ]
"Give me a day,
and then I'll get right to
raping and murdering."
[ Laughter ]
-You can't do that exhausted.
You just can't do it exhausted.
-No.
-Paris? How was Paris?
-Paris was amazing.
I guess I was there
like eight days ago,
and I am still
digesting the cheese.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-My delicate American body...
...could not handle
the cheese-cheese.
-Yeah, because you eat cheese
here in the States.
-My wife is from Wisconsin.
I love cheese.
-Yeah.
-But the cheese --
the French have a --
They take eating cheese
to a whole other level.
They make it an entire course
at the meal.
So you'll have an appetizer,
an entrée,
and then for absolutely
no reason at all,
a bunch of chunks of cheese,
then dessert.
After that you go to
the hospital.
[ Laughter ]
But it's amazing.
It's not like I don't eat cheese
that way,
but just not in public.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Eating chunks of cheese,
that's what I get caught doing.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
The first time
I had the cheese course,
I actually heard my heart say,
"Are you mad at me?"
[ Laughter ]
My brain took over.
It's like, "It's going to be
fine. Everyone relax. Relax.
There's going to be sweating.
There's going to be
a lot of sweating.
[ Laughter ]
You know, bowels, you can take
a couple weeks off."
[ Laughter ]
But it was amazing.
I tried dozens of
French cheeses,
and I couldn't tell you
the name of one of them.
And they told me the names.
They'd be like,
"This is Shaw-shaw-shaw
from the Shaw-shaw-shaw region."
And I'd be like,
"So not cheddar?"
[ Laughter ]
It was amazing.
-You also made it
to Scandinavia.
-I did. Scandinavia.
-Finland.
-Finland. I went all around
the Nordic countries
and ate a lot of reindeer.
-You did. You're not joking.
This is a photo you took.
-Yes.
-There was a place
that was selling reindeer.
-This was, I think, in Finland.
But in Norway, I went in
a butcher shop,
and they had a sale
on reindeer meat.
Nothing says
Christmas season is over...
[ Laughter ]
...quite like a sale
on reindeer meat.
[ Laughter ]
That's got to be
a tough day for Santa.
[ Laughter ]
"I want to thank
all the reindeer
for your work this year.
Now, when I call your name,
if you could come with me
in the smokehouse.
Donner!"
[ Laughter ]
But it was amazing.
-Stockholm?
-Stockholm.
-Beautiful city.
-Beautiful city, and you know,
you go to so many
of these places,
and you really want to
experience
the tourist attraction.
In Stockholm, the big attraction
is the Vasa Museum,
which is a ship museum.
But there is -- You go there,
and there's only one ship.
So it's less of a museum.
It's like a ship garage.
[ Laughter ]
And you learn --
I learned that this ship,
essentially it floated
for like a moment,
and then it sunk in
Stockholm Harbor.
So their museum is a boat
that didn't float.
[ Laughter ]
Like, most countries, their
largest tourist attraction is,
you know, an engineering marvel,
or some beautiful natural thing.
In Stockholm, they're like "This
is a boat that didn't float.
This is why we make furniture."
[ Laughter ]
But it is a beautiful boat.